hi guys today I'm back playing part to a
friend bro for you so let's just carry
on because laws of you actually enjoyed
the first episode and I did a lot so
yeah let's continue so we just left off
she went up the stairs and um what
happens that weird shadow thing Oh what
I think that's just a light the wick
yeah the weighted shadow thing came and
basically told her that she wasn't gonna
find a cat I think in and she's like no
mr. Barry Wolfe I do and he told her to
meet him at the end of the maze and yeah
Mr Burnett is dry is called with mr. so
that's where we're going where are we
now Robert Clark observation failed
anesthetic the patient woke up after
reaching frontal lobe the procedure was
canceled and in completed okay then so
the dude you lobotomies oh that are so
creepy the operating room I don't want
to go inside it smells like rotten flesh
oh you can smell that from out there
take the pills oh gosh oh so creeped oh
gosh it's focused now who is that so
wake up oh my gosh oh that's actually
really cool it's focusing wherever the
cursor is
oh ok ah never fails give me cherez
shivers shivers ok man speak right what
the hell my path to life has been denied
I haven't been born but I was alive I'm
waiting for a mother to love me oh my
gosh you can't blame those who are
ignorant but you can't let ignorance
decide life will teach you even through
pain and tears wow I don't know what is
that even about I don't I have no
explanation for why I just saw and it
kind of freaks me out whatever so can
these Oh are the or lobotomy patients I
want if I leave this sick place yeah you
need to leave was I saying what does
that say it would it says it word I
don't know what it means I don't know
what that means either I was trying to
say it backwards in my head doo doll tee
but that doesn't work either okay that's
strange wonder what it would means
remind me to google that ok oh this is
horrible hello are you resting did you
puke that's disgusting I hope you get
well soon
oh boy why do you have your brain out is
it too warm in there he won't answer ah
alice is horrible yes I took the new one
upstairs Fran bow no I haven't seen her
what's the key to the cellar well no and
the doctor's office he used to have the
key there calm down the key is not here
sure I'll let you know if it turns up
but you must calm down yes I'll bring it
to if I find it all right bye I have it
Kiki or I did have it I used it oh my
goodness I can't believe this I'm at the
reception already this is grand but the
nurse I have to get rid of her yeah you
do maybe we should give her the bun miss
nares i hope you want to go to the
toilet soon ok ah how should do this
what should I do okay um well I had the
most professional setup ever no idea um
I'm i doing I use the drugs to move on
with you know doesn't work hmm oh the
note i have said something about this
turn off the alarm from the security
system pattern panel in reception okay
the yellow door will remain in from two
minutes until the alarm reactivates okay
but I need to get around there first I
know how do I get rid of you stupid
nurse let's see what pills do at the end
of the maze I'm coming I'm coming mr.
bin night I wonder what's at the end of
the maze this have been a obviously
whatever it is i hope i can find my
kitty yeah me too oh you're skinny yeah
why are you hanging up there oh it's a
fetus are you okay this baby oh it's a
natural wavy is that your mummy how
you're not there do you miss her I miss
my mommy too oh that's that's pretty
revolting well the key holder has no
keys two holes but maybe I can put the
key back on the key holder yes there you
go i hope the nurse sees the key yeah me
too right let's go stand back to around
here then we can hide from miss nurse
right I'll the key was there after all I
better take it back how's she not see
hurt is this like some stupid power like
whenever I take my pills and just
invisible to the other world obviously
so yes ok now I can do stuff
ah right ok what was it december
december seven teeth and july the 25th
12 + 17 is oh god don't judge me its
twenty nine seven eight nine yeah ok so
just 29 and that is 25 plus seven six
position to 30 30 30 30 age in July yeah
so five six seven yeah 30 yeah 32 so 29
and 32 ok 29-32 yeah oh it's like super
Fraser so happy math is not my strong
point but I did it anyway I'm sure you
guys would have time waiting for me but
it's fine hey nurse I don't like that
nice at all oh let's go let's go it's
only open for a two minutes outside
freedom sirens okay let's go
no don't call me a [ __ ] I'll make you
pay for what you did what I do I'm just
escaping you're cutting kid's head off
oh wow that goes your head oh hello you
clever little girl do you think you can
just leave no reason to be wrecking what
it can't be no is it mr. midnight what's
the hell are you what it's kind of like
mr. midnight but it's mechanical version
okay let's just go let's follow the
little weird thing with a pillow under
here anymore yeah to me this is exciting
don't like that man let's go are we
being chased oh wow look at the art
style I love it so cool wait wait oh
okay wait we gotta be quick cuz I don't
want to lose this kitty this way this
way why did he go please don't leave me
mr. lid net robotic own version no
that's not visible that's not mr.
midnight where did he go mr. midnight I
lost him I'm scared mr. big night where
did you go oh I can hear him I can hear
him he's run this am I oh oh
I just got to get over there come on can
I use my nah penny is my allergies that
sucks okay quick oh my god that was
funny nope
come on we can do this I think he's over
this way yes cool at the end of the maze
you will find the evil critters of the
night I don't want to find them do I
they will hunt you they will laugh but
there will always be a good side a cat
full of nuts and bolts will always be
your guide
no her family picture
she lose her family picture she was
gonna guard that with her life chapter 2
part 1 curiosity symptoms the teddy bear
oh my goodness that was close there are
you you can be from out of the tunnel
you are I hope the guards don't find the
sewer let's get out Oh what is this
place I hope I'll try mr. midnight soon
well you're in the forest and he said he
would wait for you in the forest so
let's have a look at this junk which is
cool I remembered something funny what
was it a very old uncle tried to blow on
one of these ha say it oh this
instrument is pretty look at the horse
head what a pretty horse a king would
like this one need probably would oh I
wish we could have taken them all with
us see ya your arm is gone get out your
heart bleeding true Wow piano sounds old
I can touch the piano and play with it
but Sir should not play it okay I took
the pills Wow
oh oh it can be good to have a cozy
place to stay it's not as creepy as it
was my asylum which I am thankful for
a tree okay take the pills Wow see I
always did the pills cuz even those
creepy sometimes it's the only way
curiosity is damned damn you curiosity
oh I like to be curious otherwise how
will you learn things very true very
true um but what are you you are kind of
curious yourself what is the right
question but why should be more
appropriate I don't have time to chat
sir I want the key that's all oh but
that key isn't ours and it's not yours
for sure I don't have time oh yeah ah
it's always good to have an extra key
especially when you're up to something
who could care who couldn't yeah we
couldn't care less the affection towards
you is simply none oh my name is Fran
and I'm a person and you interesting
tell us more I had a cat I have a cat
well I had one he's missing now I have
to find him really ah yes really now
please give me the key look person front
we came from the south flying as always
and one of us got curious about this key
and all of us got stuck here and because
of our long hair which can't get loose
so you are all curious can I help you we
usually get stuck on trees but we have
something to fix that a beautiful comb
to comb our hair every time we get stuck
alright do that then there is a problem
a filthy thief took the cone now we are
stuck forever if you find the thief and
the comb you will have the key deal yes
but what does he look like it's a rat a
filthy narcissus rat he took a comb to
be beautiful we couldn't do much so he
ran away with it please find it in free
us from curiosity I hope he hasn't gone
too deep in the forest I'll find him
we'll be here waiting okay but the heads
are quite nice I think okay so I need to
find a narcissistic rat I wonder how how
simple that'll be okay oh I saw this I
want their screenshots I'm such a
fangirl of this game wow this is a
really big insect years going curse
gross oh wow you're a really big ant
who's that oh excuse me sir are you real
ah you always ask the same thing always
me as a nude met friend before always
what do you mean by always of course I'm
real where'd you come from Oh a escape
the mental hospital but please don't
tell anyone everyone just think she's
crazy I won't tell don't worry but what
are you doing here um bad things real
bad things happen to me but now I'm
looking for my cat I catch you say
yes sir a black cat were very big yellow
eyes mr. midnight oh I see I'm sorry
girl please at least tell me if you saw
him around here it happens to be that
the cat is eaten what chewed and
swallowed eaten what do you mean the
black cat that came towards me in a
hurry a catch it I give it to my beetle
pig wait what this mr. midnight is in
this thing my beetle pic is hungry oh my
poor bees will fake hasn't had any food
in days the blueberry time passed by and
we ate them all stop it Kadri see mr.
midnight is the only one I have please
tell me you're joking how little girl
don't cry I can sing for you if you like
what if the aschen eaten what will I do
now you don't know how it feels to be
alone i dunno yes I'm the last one alive
let me help you yes how can you help how
could you possibly help me the digestion
is not so fast you know maybe he's still
in luck as a elit alive inside the
little beetle pig so he's gonna kill his
pet to get our pet out that it's quite
nice of him it's disgusting Oh make it
for me okay I think it's gonna yeah
never mind should i do something like
make the beat quick vomit kill the
beetle pig okay so it is killing he is
also the only friend I have left but I
need the meat he's gonna eat be too big
I'm curious to know if my kitty is still
in there do it you can kill the beetle
pig and I assholio the greatest shall
eat the meat
yeah can't you kill the beetle buddy I
don't worry want to kill the bees opaque
oh you Pig did you eat my cats mr.
midnight just wait don't die I'll take
you out that real soon how am I supposed
to kill him I've only got a crayon music
playing with make you vomit okay sir oh
he is falling asleep oh ok this kind of
reminds me of like a really demented
Alice in Wonderland does it remind you
you're honest and wonderland I love it I
love our lesson 12 honestly I love Alice
madness to you that as a brilliant game
play the original one will be saved by
the owl you look like an owl is that it
your fellows beautiful oh I didn't I
didn't do the pills on this one oh ok
they're just go on they just vanish
they're not they're not here oh gee ok
anyway let's get the axe Oh compelled
kill the beetle pig with the axe I feel
so mean oh the terrible acts I will be
the warrior or something self is
something didn't read the rest oh cool
what is this
make an entry a well I could try to open
it and see what's inside I can't move
the top it's stuck just my love I can't
force it my delicate hands delicate
hands I need something else okay we'll
try the axe in a second let's just see
if if if mr. midnight is actually in
here this is so gross people food come
back here that won't be till pig
so i'm guessing an eater and trap him
somehow he's still sleeping wake up the
pink ones day still it seems that
shouting and pushing won't help maybe I
have to try something more subtle use
the crayon here we get oh it's a feather
I can take all him and then maybe this
sub midnight will come out I love the
tentacle even if it works I wouldn't
know for what purpose you tickle him
Gingka no I the only one that's thinking
is this [ __ ] can tickle you nickle
tickle ah the threat is great great ah
sorry but the beetle big get scared
every time I try to kill it oh I see but
that's completely normal isn't it ah yes
but what should i do then you have to
give him the special berries the
blueberries mmm
I see but where do I find these berries
I shouldn't say this year but I have the
right connections but they live inside
my house they have blueberries okay Oh
your house my house is in that direction
be careful oh thank you sir okay should
I go to his house first or go down that
well I think I'll go to his house no
it's okay it's not actually him grumpy
peep look Fred I'm in danger find me
alive find me dead people find me some
day in a golden cage oh ok
that was odd I'll if it was bad a little
tiny house what in in the mushroom okay
let's go here this must be the aunts
house it seems to be okay it open but
very stuck the power of destruction will
take it down okay then Exodus oh no I
broke the door a door handle to handle
big problems I don't know why I needed
door handle okay I'll take it whatever I
take it all whoa ah it's got a nice
little cozy house meet hung up on the
walls okay because that make sense even
if I wanted to take the meat I can't
reach it this is odd I thought ants
never cook their meals hmm I thought
they were vegetarians but obviously I
was wrong someone forgot to clean the
brush oh I got blue I shouldn't take
other stuff but I want super glue okay
the queen of meat like aunt porn
brilliant idea what we're looking for
again oh yeah berries there's water in
the sink no that's good but where's the
berries um what is this underpants it
equips mmm teach em sir oh maybe these
are the various small ants oh it's so
cute hello oh no sorry didn't mean to do
that wow you are very rare so you look
so angry your family is very nice sir
pine cone lady fine comb what're you
cooking
don't be scared i just want some fairies
oh no the blueberries out that hurts
okay so I nice guy this gym and then I
can pick a dick oh oh darn it hmm how
can i get these pinecones I mean various
how can I get the berry super glue him
to the stick maybe i can combine some
things oh I put some glue on a handle
and where should I paste it I have no
idea
oh oh look she got some me you wouldn't
mind if I take some little meat for
there's an hunger okay
maybe I can use the lead to destruction
oh okay I'm stuck oh hello
that's weird one last thing I thought
two pills oh wow I'm not taking that bag
not with all these ants on it slick
goodness a pest exterminator and he's
dead Wow okay so i am going to follow
that Ghost because maybe i need to go
down the well before i do this or maybe
i'm just being stupid but we'll see
oh it's not house anymore oh gosh i hate
the noises okay
it's a smoke coming out of the chimney
okay let's follow that Ghost woman she
talks in belt about the pinecones not
allowing inside the berries they won't
allow me to take them they will never
allow anything if you trap one of them
maybe it will be easier okay so i'll go
down the well first did you tell weird
things here when you take the pills it's
pretty cool though what a bluff there's
no hole here what no hole hmm all my
forces united to do something
unnecessary true oh maybe I've got to
use a keypad
because it's telling me to make an entry
negative hmm very interesting hmm
nothing yeah oh my god scary so bad okay
Wow ok I think that's it for now cuz i
am stuck but i will come back very soon
and I'm sure I'll find a way out of this
rut then way I hope you've enjoyed give
it a thumbs up if you did and let me
know in the comments what you think
about this if it reminds you of a really
warped version of Alice in Wonderland
and how much you were enjoying it anyway
have a lovely day or evening bye ok
let's do the pills oh my gosh oh
that's horrible I know they did it all
wrong